22 de junio el sol se asoma en el
Atlántico indicando que la hora cero
llegó las 96 horas de reserva de oxígeno
que tenía el titán el submarino que
exploraba los restos del Titanic con
cinco tripulantes a bordo desaparecidos
desde el 18 de junio se agotaron
cada ser humano es diferente algunas
personas pueden vivir con más presión
otras con menos no hay mucho que hacer
para que el oxígeno dure debes estar
tranquilo pero cuando estás estresado tu
consumo va a ser el doble o el triple
significa que las 96 horas no están
garantizadas
una expedición programada para ocho días
que salió desde la isla de Terranova en
Canadá los dos primeros días son en la
embarcación Horizon Arctic hasta llegar
al punto de inmersión la cual toma dos
horas en bajar hasta unos 4.000 metros
de profundidad allí el submarino tiene
un recorrido aproximado de 4 horas por
los restos del Titanic que naufragó en
1912 y luego debería tomar tras dos
horas para regresar a la superficie
titán logró su primera expedición en
2021 y desde entonces lleva a
millonarios al fondo del océano con La
Única condición que no sufran de
claustrofobia es el único submarino que
transporta civiles en una cápsula en la
que apenas alguien puede ponerse de pie
con pocas provisiones de comida o agua
un baño de emergencia y comunicaciones
inestables una expedición criticada por
la falta de pruebas como Chris Brown un
desertor de este último viaje
partes del submarino que había visto en
las pruebas de las Bahamas parecían un
poco de mala calidad usaron tuberías
industriales como lastre y un control de
Xbox como timón pero lo que realmente me
disuadió fue que se negaron rotundamente
a Obtener cualquier tipo de
certificación
entre las teorías de lo sucedido está
que el titán se pudo atascar con los
restos del Titanic ser arrastrado por
una corriente submarina o que pudo
implosionar por la presión un misterio
que quedará enterrado en la oscuridad
perpetua del océano